violette du ccre et m cette fête de
fiançailles et bien sûr la célébration
d'un avenir nouveau mais il est
important d'y explorer d'abord le passé
magritte à quai annappes il ya les
aigrettes sac aurait mis notre courrier
est livré à mahmoud pis pour ceux qui
croient qu'on a compris nos gens c'est
une nette de l'université de michigan
il m'offre un contrat pour deux ans deux
ans c'est rien du tout réunies ouais on
mettra notre mariage après ça tu
avoueras que je mérite une super partie
de jambes en l'air pour ça tu veux que
je pars tu nous tiens genre je sais pas
je veux le grand jeu et hervé seck du
soleil c'est le genre de truc et twitter
au michigan
on s'adapte au profil au corps vous avez
déjà fixé votre date pas encore mais on
sait que c'est important de
félicitations vous avez obtenu une
promotion vous rester quelques années de
plus chez nous terme vu que t'es dur j
med qui en auraient pour deux ans c'est
comme être sera tapis de course et se
dire tiens je vais encore me faire 5 km
aujourd'hui et tout d'un coup c'est
kilométrage illimité
c'était quand la dernière fois que tapie
dit à bydgoszcz excusez moi je pense pas
qu'on puisse résoudre tous nos problèmes
avant un mariage mais je te promets je
t'aimerai à chaque étape du parcours
vous avez une idée de la date à laquelle
vous allez vous marier les grands
parents où il fera chaud scandant ça ne
fait notamment ils sont quand tout cela
pour la fouille et voilà pourquoi on
évite de retarder les mariages c'est un
corps de réflexion tu vas etre trés
jolie demoiselle d'honneur mois chip à
carcassonne